young very early suggested in a book
called flying sauce isn't a modern myth
of things seen in the sky that he
published in 1948 that it was in fact a
projection of the mass psyche that it
was a similar bull to the goals of our
chemical transubstantiation he called it
the Rotunda the scintilla the spark the
spinning thing and it's all these things
but it is it is the clue that we are
somehow trapped inside some kind of
artifice that that the world that we're
inside of is much more like a work of
art than it is like the smooth running
mechanistic machine that Newtonian
science describes that description works
very well for all low-grade phenomena up
to about the level of the weather but
from there on that the notion that the
world is simply you know probabilistic
process is following these various
Creoles of least resistance becomes very
untenable because each of us in our
experience of being lives in a highly
theatrical world and what I mean by that
is that you can see a woman at a great
distance from you in class in
opportunity all of these things and you
fall in love with this woman and it's
hopeless but of course as we all know
it's also inevitable and that
inevitability totally violates physics
because it really is hopeless how is it
then that each of our lives is a work of
art of unbelievable chance encounters
coincidences and wish
is projected onto the world but never
spoken and strangely fulfilled in the
oddest ways I think that it's because
the world is made of language and that
if the eastern conception that the
universe is mind has any operational
impact in the world it will be through
conceiving of mind as the underlying
self-aware self active world forming
grammar of being so that the what Freud
called the super-ego what I call the
Overmind
there have been different ways of
talking about it has to be seen not as a
passive homeostatic controlling device
but actually as the most intelligent
organization on this planet and we are
all only components of this believing
ourselves to be the highest expression
of freedom but it is actually at the
species level that organization is
controlled and that's why the emergence
of ideas like the calculus or the
invention of LSD or the steam engine why
these things have this curious property
of being regulated from above it's
because the world is not nearly as
chaotic and random as we suppose we are
actually trapped inside a giant organism
and it is not Gaia that's a much larger
organism we are trapped inside a large
organism which is the human collectivity
and that's why we are such different
monkeys because there is this group mind
which none of us is aware of or has ever
perceived that is actually mediating the
human experience and it is no more
apprehend about to us than the group
mind of an anthill is apprehend a bull
to us it can't be seen what it is is
it's an interlocking set of conventions
linguistic
directions genetic components
assumptions and what for lack of a
better word you would call innate
tendencies and these things which we
wear as as the clothing of our species
hood are actually the constraints
directing us first one way and then
another and if we want to take control
of our destiny we are going to have to
rise into empathy with this over mind
the super-ego
[Music]
[Music]